en écoutant la phobie implacable de la russie
dans cet endroit
pourquoi les gens sont-ils surpris que la russie
ne voit aucun
intérêt à s'engager avec l'ue je suis aussi
heureux que n'importe qui d'autre de défendre
les droits de quiconque,
y compris celui de navalny, mais soyons honnêtes
à son sujet,
c'est un vicieux anti-  immigrant raciste
sur peut-être quatre pour cent du soutien pour
rassembler des centaines et des milliers dans des
villes de millions à
peine un mouvement de masse et nous
ne parlerions pas
du tout de lui s'il avait été arrêté
ailleurs qu'en
russie pendant ce temps julian assange a été
incarcéré  pendant près de
10 ans pour nous avoir dénoncé des crimes de guerre,
nous ne pouvons pas mentionner son nom